[Música]
lá espero que estejam confortáveis eu
não estou para os próximos dois minutos
ao menos falar sobre o que sabemos e não
sabemos sobre a sustentabilidade das
cidades e por que isso é importante
eu já há algum tempo têm vindo a estudar
e tentar compreender as trajetórias
insustentáveis desenvolvimento das
sociedades atuais ea minha formação base
a economia anda de uma é obter um
perceber a importância de diminuirmos e
avaliamos realizado pela coréia é
através de indicadores mas muitas vezes
associado indicadores apenas números e
aquilo que a minha formação e com a
minha não deu foi a forma entusiasta de
olhar para os números muito para além da
visão objetiva e particular da realidade
que nos pretendem dar só mais tarde
percebi que os indicadores podem nos dar
uma visão muito mais extraordinária do
que uma visão monocórdicas dos números
nos permitem nos despertar consciências
dos indicadores permitem tornar palpável
e visível é que o que é abstrato é
difícil compreender como a
sustentabilidade e nada mais abstrato
que o ar
conseguimos nós pensar que o avião tinha
peso até o século 17 o ato simbolizava
nada até galileu galilei ter
científicamente provado o contrário
não sabíamos que marte tinha peso
sabemos que o ar tem peso e hoje vemos
que o ato é uma competição muito
diferente nas cidades e fora dela
hoje vemos em tempo real e 300 contra as
concentrações de poluentes
os bingos e avaliarmos quanto ar provoca
doenças respiratórias
o quanto à mata os indicadores têm esta
capacidade nos fazer compreender um todo
nos fazer interligar o conhecimento mas
mais do que isso nos fazer é usar a
nossa própria desafiar a nossa própria
percepção do mundo e da realidade e
confessa que foi exatamente isso que
aconteceu com um só indicador e há cerca
de nove anos atrás eu trabalho com
indicadores há mais de 18 anos e tenta
usar os indicadores para usar
portão - para futuros mais sustentáveis
mas consegui ser surpreendida com um
apenas há cerca de nove anos que mudou a
minha perceção do mundo
eu trago aqui esse indicador já neste
gráfico muito simples é publicado em
2009 pela equipe de cientistas liderada
por rolando rockstrom e este gráfico com
cintos mostrou ontem segundo planeta
terra
os últimos 100 mil anos do planeta terra
ea oscilação incrível da temperatura
média do planeta terra ao longo destes
cem mil anos espantem se comemos pantai
como foi possível mussum e nos últimos
oito a dez mil euros o planeta é
temperatura do planeta terra estabilizou
estabilizou a níveis continuamente
simpáticos para nós seres humanos
tivesse pensado nos mínimos já que os
picos criminal e futuramente nós teremos
aqui pra falar sobre tráfico e foi esta
estabilização nos permitiu descobrir a
agricultura nos permitiu desenvolver
enquanto as civilizações até ao dia de
hoje
e este é o único trio na vida da terra
que nos garantiu este desenvolvimento e
este período da vida da terra os
cientistas chamaram de alcino
o drama é olhar para este mais em pensar
que ela é passado
ela só não representam presente nós já
não estamos priorizando assim nós não
estamos na era de lógica do assassino de
150 anos pra cá o homem iniciou uma
cruzada que nos fez aquilo que está
terça-feira de lógica e entrar numa
outra era do antropoceno e esta era uma
era cheia de certeza dúvidas de muitas
perguntas sobre o futuro da humanidade
no planeta terra não o futuro do planeta
terra o futuro da humanidade no planeta
então o que temos feito em 1950 anos pra
cá ou mais especificamente a 60 anos
para cá onde explorarmos o nosso impacto
sobre o planeta terra de uma forma
dramática
seguramente grande parte esta opção
técnica o crescimento da população
mundial nós triplicamos a população
mundial
em pouco mais de 60 anos e concentrados
sobretudo esta população ensinados
hoje vemos que a população urbana em
termos mundiais é mais limitado que a
população total estima se que até 2050
dois terços da população mundial fifa
já em finados as cidades são hoje o
centro dos problemas mas sobretudo
centro das soluções para o nosso futuro
e nas cidades que nós criamos a grande
parte da riqueza do mundo na cidade que
nós criamos mais de 70% da riqueza
mundial mas também na cidade nós temos
as maiores desigualdades sociais
é nas cidades que nós consumimos grande
parte da riqueza produzida nível mundial
6069 é conseguir assinados e mais de 70%
das emissões de gases com efeito estufa
é produzida por força das atividades que
ocorrem nas cidades e as emissões de
gases com efeito estufa são as grandes
responsáveis principais responsáveis
pelas mudanças climáticas e sobretudo
por esta nova era do antropoceno em que
estamos agora na china que por tudo
aquilo que consumimos geramos mais 30%
dos resíduos produzidos em todo mundo e
por isso mesmo nós sentimos que temos as
cidades ainda não dá sinais de um futuro
grande parte do futuro do planeta terra
e me pergunta para você o que vemos nós
sobre as cidades portuguesas
conseguimos nós conhecer mesmo as nossas
cidades encontrar indicadores que nos
permitam conhecer o passado o presente e
sobretudo o futuro da nossa cidade
se você perguntasse pronto conseguiam
encontrar essa informação quando
tentaram encontrar indicadores nos
permite conhecer melhor as nossas
cidades
provavelmente diriam que como seriam
pelo nosso instituto nacional de ti ti é
um é dado oficial das estatísticas
portuguesas mas provavelmente teriam
alguma dificuldade em conseguir
encontrar a entrada ou eventualmente
sair na das estatísticas das cidades em
portugal poderiam também consultar
plataformas como a data muito mais
interativas fáceis visualizar de
comparar a informação de discutirmos a
informação estatística e onde até as
crianças têm direito primeiro set cada e
usá-la para usar os seus conhecimentos
para mudar as suas acções na minha
perspectiva com estatísticas oficiais
mas continuamos a ter uma visão atrativa
necessidades monocórdica com muito mais
é muito muito completa e com muito mais
para saber sobre elas
e portanto por que não recorrerá às
universidades onde se produz grande
parte do conhecimento científico um
grande parte da informação está a ser
trabalhada no contexto das universidades
mas provavelmente teremos que abre
muitas gazetas teremos muitas delas pelo
menos este pó algumas com indicadores
interessantes sobre as cidades mas
teremos muita dificuldade é interligar
toda a informação e sobretudo muita
dificuldade aqui essa informação xvii e
não há cidadãos e é nossa sociedade
o próximo passo realmente seria
consultar porque não é feito os vossos
municípios são as entidades que melhor
conhecem o território de mais informação
tem mais informação geral sobre as
cidades
acham que conseguiriam encontrar
informação nos sites dos nossos
municípios
a minha percepção é que não não sou ela
tá fechado a cet santos é sexados como
ela está dispersa como ela não está
sistematizado ela não está visível para
nós cidadãos e nós cidadãos não seremos
também nós responsáveis por grande parte
do crescimento das cidades e as nossas
projeções das nossas as nossas vivências
urbanas não cremos nós melhor que
ninguém
as cidades e jpa e nós somos
especialistas do carvão vivemos que é
tão difícil fazer um conhecimento
coletivo tantas pressões individuais é
tão difícil dar um sentido coletivo
quando nem sequer conhecendo nosso 5 a 0
mas para isso temos uma função smart
cities a era dos grandes dados é de btt
e das novas tecnologias que nos permitem
recolher tarde volumes de dados a uma
velocidade impressionante mas muitas
vezes somos muito mais dominados por
algoritmos do que temos a capacidade de
compreender o que só grito nos dão o que
essa informação não está me perguntei à
minha dúvida permanece
conhecemos mesmo as nossas finados somos
mesmo é capaz de refletir sobre ela
vou te dar um exemplo simples ficariam
curiosos por saber que os pólenes também
ficam estressados nas cidades como nós
os pólens produzem 10 vezes mais
proteína e são muito mais ativos na
promoção das alergias na finados do que
fora delas ficaram surpreendidos de
serra
que quebram nós em termos de circulação
mundial com sumiço mesmo que nós cada um
de nós portugueses precisaríamos de 2.3
planetas terra para manter o nosso
estilo divina e grande parte da nossa
pegada ecológica se dá por aquilo que
conseguimos nas cidades está pelo
consumo de alimentos
poderemos nós pensar que a alimentação
das finais é um dos grandes desafios
ambientais e de saúde que temos pela
frente
a minha perspectiva é que não
conseguimos transformar o que não
vencemos e temos um grande também pela
frente podemos fazer muito diferente
podemos fazer muito diferente pelas
estatísticas oficiais
não podemos penalizar democratizar o
papel das universidades na transmissão
do conhecimento para minar o papel dos
municípios e todos nós em conjunto para
fazer com que os indicadores movem as
nossas consciências
nós temos muitos exemplos de como isso é
possível em muitas cidades que já fazem
diferentes
temos exemplos como as cidades
concidades de poluição na europa dá mais
de 20 anos recolhem trabalham
indicadores contaminados e por isso
tornou-se a capital verde da europa em
temos cidades no estado que levar como é
um movimento sindical dos comunitários
surgiu na década de 90 em cidades como
vancouver o enipec mobilizam a sociedade
constroem visões de terminar com as
cidades com base em indicadores e temos
também exemplos cidades da austrália com
mel ou nos estados unidos encontra-se
com a política nacional cidades que
possam nos indicadores da forma como
conseguimos utilizá-los para mudar e
transformar as nossas cidades
a minha mensagem final é sobretudo para
que usemos e olhemos para os indicadores
de uma forma muito mais apelativa vamos
usar os vendedores para despertar as
nossas consciências para compreender que
os desafios que temos pela frente são
muito grandes para debater e comunicar
essa informação de uma forma construtiva
e para percebermos que a realidade se
trata do nosso futuro entre terminando
também para o futuro do planeta
vamos usar os indicadores para nos
mobilizar nos pés
melhorar os nossos comportamentos e
subir tudo para que através da
construção de cidades sustentáveis
consigamos prosseguir a viagem no tempo
o planeta terra
obrigado
[Aplausos]